and okay nice so hi welcome to my talk
together we will today explore what the
pad what it can do and what it cannot do
first of all something about me I'm
tilman i'm working as a deep learning
engineer at ivy digital lab where we are
doing you know the future of engineering
and i'm also a PhD student at your
berlin under professor Kaman Speedman
where i'm doing research about bless you
i'm doing research about predictive
maintenance and transfer learning now
that we've got that out of the way what
are we even talking about today or what
i'm i talking but we want to learn about
the JIT which is short for just-in-time
compiler just-in-time compiler is just a
compiler that runs during the execution
time of your program and just-in-time
compiles the source code or the byte
code into machine code in our special
case it means that the JIT will compile
the forward function of our neural
network model which is written in Python
and in the pad word framework into a
computation graph every as we should
know it from frameworks like tens of
flow or so on this computation graph can
then be directly executed in the C++
runtime of pide watch which means no
more call they expect Python this has
several pros especially for one use case
which is deployment you can use it for
development too but here maybe the
dynamic structure of the Python defined
computation in Python is more there it's
better for you while developing but in
deployment e1 maybe your static graph
for easy export and for optimization
yeah in the title of the talk I made
some promises just a quick reminder the
proposal for the talk is was some time
ago and these promises are based on my
my understanding that I had at of the
time about the JIT and also on a
different high Tatra version then we
have today so when I started working on
this we still had one point zero one or
something and now we have one point two
so something's changed but today we will
explore if or how these promises are
fulfilled by the title sheet first
promise is minimize dependencies so you
don't want to put all your development
code on your diploma deployment system
you want to move minimum of code a
minimum of data from one system to the
other we will see how that works then
probably you don't want your plain code
on your deployment system for nosy
people like your customers and you want
to your network to be as fast as
possible in deployment that means we
want to boost performance performance
here really execution speed not accuracy
or something like that so first of all
we're going to do some imports you know
this is a live part of Drupada notebook
so everything I do here will be life and
maybe breaks I hope not but first of all
we're doing the inputs so we're getting
tight watch at the torch vision library
which just contains some pre trained
vision models that we are going to use
and we are importing the JIT module
itself and then just some stuff that I'm
going to need for this presentation the
network we are working with will be alex
net which will be free trained the
reason for alex net is it's simple and
my laptop is not that powerful and if we
want to stay in the 30 minutes we have
to take something simple so first we're
going to execute our imports and then
we're having a look at our network
structure as we can see your elect net
really simple we have a feature
extractor of convolution layers we have
an average pool and then we have a
classifier which consists of fully
connected layers and as we can see the
all the information that we need about
the network like which kind of
convolutions which kernel size which is
right everything is in there so
everything we need to know about the
network structure we can learn from this
print basically next we want to build
our control group so now we have our
elects net and we want to move it to a
deployment system how can we do that
there are basically two ways two
conventional ways to save a model in pi
torch and a more yeah
exotic way the first one would be just
pickling the whole object which is not
the recommended way by the way so we're
using the torch that safe command which
uses pickle under the hood and just
saves the whole object a pattern object
to a file works the second way which is
the recommended way for doing it without
the JIT is just saving the weights of
your network so the weights and all the
buffers of the PI torch network are
saved in the state dict of the network
and we can just take the static which is
just a Python dictionary and then save
it to a picker file the difference is
that we now would need to reinstate the
object ourselves and load the static
back into the object we can do that to
the more exotic way would be exporting
and onyx graphics or on extend for open
neural network exchange format which is
really nice because if we export it like
that we can import it in other
frameworks like cafe 2 or I think MX net
or something like that so to do that we
need to build the network graph with an
exemplary input set our network to Evo
because we can change that later and
then just export it with the Onix export
function and get an Onix file that takes
a little bit longer because it has to
build the graph first but now we have
three different files on our disk where
we saved our network ok this is our
control group now we're going to move on
- how to use the JIT itself is pretty
simple and looks a little bit like the
Onyx stuff so first we define an
exemplary input for our network which
would be this random noise image there
we set our network to evil again and
then we're going to trace the model so
there are two ways to using the JIT one
is tracing the other scripting tracing
is the easier one and I'm going to stay
in trigger with tracing Europe just
because scripting would be a whole talk
on itself and this is an introductory
talk so we're going to trace for now
tracing just means we pipe the exemplary
input through our network and each
operation is recorded and then put into
the computation graph this graph is then
saved to a script module or a trace
module which we can have a look at then
so this is the computation graph and I
think nobody can read it so it's not
really that human readable anymore but
it does exactly the same as the forward
function of the LX net does now that we
have our computation graph we can save
it to disk which we do with added safe
command which works just like the torch
dot safe command but for traced in
scripted models which works too and
we're good to go
basically that's it so this is how you
use digit for saving your model now
we're gonna head over to our deployment
system and see if how it all works out
so to do that we are just going to use
another Chiappetta notebook which is not
only separate from the true parallel
port but also runs in a separate virtual
environment so that we really have a
clean cut between our development and
our deployment system so for the
deployment environment again we are
going to import some stuff so we're
going to import torch the JIT numpy and
all the stuff we need for deployment and
as you can see here we are not importing
torch vision
the reason is that torch vision is not
even installed in this environment so
Tatra vision would be the contains the
code for our network and we maybe don't
want to have the code for a network on
our deployment system so it's not there
and we will see how it works out for all
the ways we saved our models so this is
our deployment code which is just a
small function that takes an image from
disk types it through the network and
says which class Network Chrome
predicted and now we're going to see how
if our first promise is fulfilled we are
we will see how the JIT minimized the
repentance ease of our network so first
we are going for our control group we
are trying to load the whole pickled
path an object and we will fail because
pickle in the background tries to
automatically instantiate the Python
object that we saved and it can only do
that if it has the Python code for that
and as taught revision is not installed
it can find the pattern code and it can
tree instantiate the object this is also
why this is not a recommended way to
save a model because if you're doing
some refactoring or use change something
on your on your pattern code of your
model and try to load an old version it
won't work anymore because the pattern
code is different or the Python code is
not even there so best practice is
saving only the way it's because then
you can in the event of refactoring
happening can stitch it together
yourself so this doesn't work next thing
would be loading this tactic which would
be the recommended thing to do which we
can do just fine but as I said we still
need the Python code to get the
architecture of our network and we don't
have that so while we now have to wait
we don't have the architecture and we
can do any inference with that it
doesn't work too so the last one the
exotic one would be onyx and I'm not
[ __ ] you
Python has no import function for onyx
you can only export it so I don't know
what they thought but even the tutorial
says okay now we're exporting it from
height watch and we're loading it in
cafe - and cafe - was merged into Pyatt
watch and cafe - has an import function
but title not I don't know what happened
there but it was not good so can't use
that either now the G to the rescue
we're going to try to load our traced
model with the G load load function
which works obviously the load function
here works just as the tortured load
function would with the difference that
if you would have saved with torch that
safe from the GPU torch load would put
it try to put it on the GPU again and
get that load always puts it on the CPU
first and you have to move it then
that's the only difference basically but
Jade load works on traced models so now
that we have our model we can use it in
deployment we are going to take this
little JPEG there and just try if our
pre-trade model works as intended which
it does because it knows that is a
picture of a cat which means we
successfully cut out all of the
development code that we have as a
dependency which is just what we wanted
to do but the JIT doesn't stop there
maybe you not only want to cut out your
to a package code a pattern code but
also Python itself so what if you want
to deploy in C++ that's pretty easy
actually because Python has now without
think 1.0 a c++ interface and we can
just load the traced model into c++
which is pretty simple I just hope
nobody here is a C++ expert because I'm
not and I can say some weird stuff now
what we're doing is we're importing the
script header which has all of the stuff
that we need for loading and using a
script as traced module for
we're going to bless you instantiate the
script module of over there
can do a fill I have moss here we
instantiate the CREP module and then we
are just using the same load function
that we wrote F used in Python to load
the model with the path that we get from
our first command-line argument if it
throws an error something went wrong
otherwise we get in okay and that's it
that's how you load the model it's
pretty simple because the pilot team
tried to threat for the C++ interface to
be as similar to the pattern interface
as possible using it is basically the
same so first you have to build your
input vector so you're using a standard
vector from C++ of I values which is a
little bit different but your casting is
done automatically so you take a random
tender push it into your vector and then
you're defining an output tender and
then you just call the forward function
on your input vector get an eye value
back convert it to in tensor and got
your output this is pretty simple and
you not only have to take you don't have
to take my word for it I implemented it
myself with a lot of help of the
documentation so we're going to take our
trace model put it into the example app
get an okay and then it will run ten
times and then output a profiling file
that we can later inspect to see what
our network has done so now we even cut
out the Python dependency itself so I'd
say the promise of minimizing
dependencies gets a check mark moving on
with the success under the hood we are
on a see if we can hide our code with
digit so as I said we cut out the
pattern code itself so there is no plain
text code floating around of our network
in our deployment system but can we
somehow
still see what the network is about so
we're just trying to print now or trace
Network and we can see that the overall
architecture with the feature extractor
and the classifier and the average fool
is still there but the modules itself
don't have this detailed information
anymore that it had before but maybe we
can go some little bit further and we'll
see what kind of information we can get
out of our network so we are going to
have a look at all of the functions that
our network module has and it's a lot
and there are some duplicates but the
most interesting one would be this year
which is called code this is a property
function and we are just going to see
what it contains and it's just the
Python code of our model it looks a
little bit contrived because it's not
basically it's not Python code its torch
script which is a subset of Python that
the JIT understands so some convenience
functions are missing but in the end as
you can see you have the convolution
here it gets the weight you know it has
this this kernel size and which try it
and if it has a bias and so on so in the
end we get the architecture of that
stuff so we get the autocratic
architecture can we access the way its
to we're just going to have a look at
what kind of member variables our first
module has of the feature extractor and
there we have the parameter dictionary
which normally contains all of the
weights so let's have a look at the keys
there and the only keys are were called
weight and pious so we're going to have
a look at the shape and get it yes it's
a tensor it has the right shape for our
first convolution so in the end
yes the code is better hidden than
having plain Python code on your
deployment system but everybody with the
Python interpreter can basically access
it so it gets a man okay not so nice but
still we have one last promise to
explore we're gonna head back to the
system we trained on because now we want
to compare the traced network in terms
of speed against the untraced network
yeah boost performance does it really
boost execution time for that we're
going to run our forward pass ten times
by 10 times just to see if how the
distribution of run times is and we can
see here we got 686 milliseconds with 61
milliseconds of standard deviation here
for 10 runs this is for the untraced
Network the first one the second one is
for the trace Network a little bit of
info about how I did this
normally if you're doing timing and
Drupada notebooks you're using the magic
time come at a time and command that
does not really work reliably here
because high torch in itself works as
incur honestly because the computation
especially the GPU computations are just
put into a queue and then executed so
the Python code can return before the
execution of the calculation is even
finished and this is why we need to use
the built-in profiler of torch which
really gives us time spent in the C++
runtime and as we can see the the price
network is a little bit faster it's not
that much but it's a little and just to
be on the statistically safe side we're
going to use a Nova to see if it's
statistically significant difference
between the runs and it's not so as we
can see here the standard deviation is
still in the range when we can use ANOVA
and in the end it's not really a
statistically significant difference
here but this is only for CPU let's head
on to GPU runtime and as you can maybe
see this laptop probably doesn't have a
dedicated CUDA capable GPU so I did this
beforehand on a machine with a 1080 Ti
and we're going to load the results and
have a the same look here and as we can
see here the network that was traced is
really faster and the difference is even
significant we have to take this with a
grain of salt because the standard
deviation of the trace one is much
smaller than the standard deviation of
the untraced one but still we're getting
two milliseconds but two milliseconds
for ten images so in the end when just
doing one image we get 0.2 milliseconds
of performance increase which is maybe
statistically significant but
practically not really we're just really
sad because this is another promise that
seems not to be fulfilled but alex net
is just one network maybe it's just too
simple there's nothing to optimize this
is why I ran the same thing for all the
networks in torch vision and as you can
see it doesn't get really better because
most of the time both types like the
trace and the untraced ones are as far
above fast but sometimes the one is a
little bit ahead and sometimes the
others a little bit ahead it's even
statistically significant because the
standard deviation is so low but in
practical terms you can't even see the
difference on this Beamer here the only
network where it really worked and the
traced one was faster was the Google net
also known as Inception be one where the
trace one is really faster and I thought
okay why is that and I looked at the
code and I can't really say the so the
code was written by the same people that
wrote all the other networks and it
there's nothing
that is really different on this network
and especially because when inception v3
is not really that much faster and it's
practically the same base of an
architecture so this is a huge problem
with the JIT that even though the part
of team says that the execution is
optimized we don't not really know what
is optimized because here it seems that
there's just nothing to optimize in this
simple feed-forward networks so in the
end whose performance gets a metwo
because statistically yes practical no
but maybe I don't know why so if any one
of you has some insight and that I'd
like to really to know so in the end our
promises again minimize dependencies
gets a definitely yes and all the both
others get a may because a bit but not
really so as a conclusion here I'd say I
will still use that because it's in what
it's supposed to do namely minimizing
dependencies for your deployment it's
really good and the other ones are at
least an improvement on the status quo
but not a really good improvement but we
will see what others and what the next
releases bring so I promised in my
abstract that I give some hands-on
advice and but I don't have that much
time so I'm just going to be really
quick first advice that I'd give is
avoid non-traceable code tracing is
really the most simple thing you can do
with a JIT scripting gets really really
hard because you have to write or quit
which is Python but it's lacking some
stuff and you don't always know what
it's lacking and the error messages are
really not that helpful so if you can
trace your code which you can always do
if you don't have any input dependent
control flows something like ifs that
are dependent on the shape or RNN stuff
that needs a dynamic
a dynamic loop a number of loops then
you can just trace it and most networks
are a feed-forward anyway so yeah then
second thing if you need to script
convert your model module by module you
can mix scripting and tracing so try to
find out which of your modules yeah it's
the problem and then only script that if
you then trace the whole module the
script module will be still there and
work is expected so you don't have to
script your whole network but only the
one module where it fails basically and
the last one is include the interface
code into your graph that just means
when you're using a deployment system
you probably want a general interface
for how it works you want to give it in
an image from your disk as an umpire
array maybe and then you're expecting it
to output the index of the most probable
class just include stuff like input
normalization softmax and all the other
stuff into your graph that makes your
code much cleaner on the deployment side
and much easier to swap out networks as
you go yeah that's it from my side this
talk is on github so you can play around
with it yourself
these C++ examples also there I put the
link on the description of the talk but
I didn't find it myself so anyway make
make a photo or something yeah that's it
and I'm open for questions
[Applause]
thanks a lot for this thorough
introduction of any questions if not I
myself have one so like my favorite
thing what I taught is actually that I
can that I do have like the full Python
control flow at my hands so how well
does the JIT compiler actually deal with
that as I tried to say tracing just
throws away all the control flow it just
records the one
mutation flow that you have if you want
to retain your your control then you
have to script it which you can most of
the time but then you have to see
are you using member variables of your
of your module you and then it's a
little bit different into our script
then it isn't Python itself and there it
gets complicated yes you can but it will
need some refactoring there was another
question over there I think do you have
any experience with torch script and
performance how that effects elements if
you mean if taught script is basically
slower than just tracing it you mean for
example not directly just from intuition
the thing is most of the modules that
there are in the dot an end module are
written and taught script so it
shouldn't make any difference because
you just stay in the C++ runtime and
yeah you don't go ever back to pilot and
so it shouldn't make a difference but I
didn't test it myself
any more questions if that's not the
case then let's thank to Munn again what
I saw
[Applause]